hello welcome to this symposium on the
only topic of the day the corona virus
my name is Larry R and I work at the
college and I'm going to introduce a
friend of mine as one of my most admired
people I just quoted him in in Primus I
read him every Monday morning faithfully
in something called the Monday morning
outlook if you search for that in his
last name
you can overwhelm his servers and I
encourage you to do that this last name
is Westbury W ESB you are why I'll tell
one little quick story about him back in
2008 when the whole world was going to
pot there was a conference of economists
in New York and I was there and I'm not
an economist I'm a man of common sense
but a lot of very distinguished
economists including Nobel Prize winners
and there was a small what would you
call it Brian it's so small conversation
among a few of them right about how the
whole world was gonna come to an end and
he predicted in front of all of them
that the stock market would be backward
was within six months and I thought that
was gutsy and the reason for that you're
about to find out is that he just looks
at the data and he's not always
optimistic and he's not always
pessimistic he just looks at the data so
Brian Westbury welcome hey thank you as
Larry it is so great to be with you
so you're the chief economist at the
first Trust Bank and he's been
practicing the dismal art now for
decades and he is however also a
liberally educated man and so we're
going to talk about what he thinks about
all this because this is unprecedented
stuff and my first question Brian is
what do you think about all this yeah
exactly well it's interesting that you
start with 2008 and that crisis because
I actually when I look back think that
laid in a way the groundwork for what
we're doing as a government as a society
today we the Federal Reserve pumped
trillions of dollars into the
economy Hank Paulson and and George Bush
the President and at the time did a 700
billion dollar bailout of the banks and
they they did this rather than and and I
and we don't need to get into all of
this but change a really simple
accounting rule actually it's not it's
it's an ugly accounting rule called
mark-to-market accounting and my view is
is that that's what created the real
damage to the economy and when we
finally change that rule in March of
2009 that's when the economy opened up
and so what we have today in my opinion
is is literally a fiasco caused in a way
by the same kinds of things that the
government through its actions
back then it was Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac that we're pushing all the subprime
loans and then mark-to-market accounting
that created this bonfire and then we
finally fixed the right thing but before
we did that we did way too much
government action and now we're doing
that again
today and so the bonfire today has been
created by these epidemiologists and
pandemic experts and if we if we kind of
think about it they've been waiting all
their lives
all their lives for for some for a
pandemic and I'm not saying that they
wish one on anyone or that they aren't
concerned about death I'm not being
cynical about them but this is what they
train for so so whenever they see
something coming MERS or SARS or
hiv/aids they start running these models
and these models you know we've seen
them in the movies right big red dots
and lines flying all over the world and
transmission and everybody dying and
what's fascinating about these models is
that if you go back over history they
almost always almost always and in fact
I'm going to say virtually always
overestimate the problem if they were
real models they would a half the time
overestimate and half the time
underestimate what I find fascinating is
that by giving our so
into these models these scientists we
have then done some things that we
shouldn't have done just like back in
2008 with quantitative easing and tarp
we should not have shut down in my
opinion our economy like we did we have
found out that these models weigh
overestimated the death and the danger
but as data has come in we've also found
out who's susceptible to dying from this
disease we know who to help and yet
politicians went along with the models
because they had to and this is a kind
of a political process right where where
if I don't go along with the worst case
model and I'm a politician then people
can say I killed people if I do go along
with the models and they come in lower
which they were highly likely to do from
the very beginning then I can say hey
see I saved the people so the models
actually determine political behavior
and in the end we ended up shutting down
the economy and I believe over the long
run the cure in this case shutting down
the economy is going to be way worse
than the disease and we can talk about
that but we have created lasting damage
to the US economy and then the final
piece of this puzzle to me is that it's
the first social media virus that we
have and so when we when we add those
three things together models that
overestimate politicians that are that
would be foolish to to to fight back to
hard once those models got out there and
the fear started to rise and then the
social media virus which literally
helped spread panic and you put those
three things together and I think we've
created a real fiasco for the US economy
I noticed that Mark Zuckerberg said a
couple days ago that he had a Facebook
that coronavirus deniers they're called
are gonna be filtered out as fringe
groups and yes the power to do that is
an
interesting powers for anybody to have -
right yeah you know go ahead just just a
quick aside I was looking back at there
was a great book written many decades
ago about groupthink and it really
studied the Bay of Pigs fiasco under
John F Kennedy and and what we end up
with is because you're forced to make
decisions under pressure and if you
decide to go against the grain then
you're called a denier and we end up and
that's when that's when very often
groups not just the government but
groups make really bad decisions and I
believe what we have today is this group
think scenario everybody thinks they
know but one of the problems that that
with if you think you know you really
don't know because all we have is the
data that is available and it's not
enough data to make a real decision and
so we have we've done some antibody
tests which show that this thing is
spread what much wider and further but
everybody ignores those because they
don't go along with the group think the
narrative and and so I think that that
that kind of language which by the way
they use with climate change as well is
really dangerous because it says there's
only one path to take and what I would
argue is that those deny that the the
coronavirus deniers are the people I
think like me who look at the damaged
and the long-term damage from the
economy we're gonna end up killing
people because of slower growth over
time because of unemployment today we
all know the reason suicide anxiety
depression violence in the home all all
of these things people being without a
job multiplies their problems and and no
one has included that in the models and
and so my and gosh if you look at Italy
and Spain and France they have
socialized medicine they've had very
little growth
for decades no wonder they have fewer
ICU beds per million people per hundred
thousand people than the u.s. does our
health care system it's it's a lot of
we've got 50% of it is run by government
but it's not Italy France or Spain and
that's why our death rates are a lot
lower and so but that's where we're
headed if we don't think about the
damage we're doing to the economy so I
would argue that if they want to call me
a coronavirus denier I'm gonna call them
an economic denier because they're not
seeing the damage that this is going to
do over time and then there's that
little factor the right to make a living
and it's to have that buy blanket orders
the governor of Michigan is particularly
tough and somebody told me the other day
he was close to the state government
that she has six or eight advisers well
of course she has six or eight advisers
right and there's not enough time in the
day for anybody to consult closely with
more people than that and so those six
or eight people are busy making lists of
what's essential and not essential in
the state of Michigan right and and
that's a it's our afraid it's all right
month long now experiment and socialism
right so what do you think the economic
consequences of this are Ryan yeah i
well you know just as in in the kind of
the short term one of the good things
you know here we are nearing the end of
April there are states opening up one of
the things that I find fascinating is is
that Florida Jacksonville area opened
its beaches within 26 minutes there were
thousands of people on the beach you can
clearly tell what people want they want
to be they want freedom and and then and
then New Yorkers are complaining about
people being on the beach outside in
Florida in the meantime the subways are
still running in New York City and by
the way one of the Fed the one of the
fascinating things about the subways in
New York City is they do have fewer
riders today that is absolutely true but
know what the system did is in response
to fewer riders they limited the number
of trains they cut the number of trains
which means that even though there's
fewer riders the cars are still full of
people they actually if they really
wanted to do the right thing they should
have increased the number of trains not
decrease the number of trains and so I
find this fascinating how different
states are dealing with things but we're
going to see Georgia is moving toward
opening South Carolina is moving toward
opening many states are Colorado is
moving and that was one of the harder
hit areas in Denver is moving toward
opening obviously Montana Wyoming Idaho
some of the western states that didn't
get hit hard and as this opens we're
going to start sealing seeing the
economy healing however we there there
are at least and and we don't have good
data on this yet but I've already heard
that in New York City ten percent of
restaurants are closed for good most we
know that the average small business in
America has about 27 days of cash and
yes the government is throwing hundreds
of billions of dollars at them but a lot
of them have given up already and so
when if let's say we would do a big bang
reopening it just it all happened at
once well we would open up probably with
only 92 percent of our economy intact
and not only that the new government
program of unemployment benefits pays
people for example in Texas for for the
next four months you can get an average
wage of fifty eight thousand dollars a
year by staying on unemployment benefits
and in many cases this is more than they
would make in their regular job so so
what's happening is we're putting a
barrier between people sitting at home
collecting unemployment or going back to
work and so we've actually damaged our
ability to recover now I do think that
America will recover it's going to be
more of a u-shaped economic recovery but
the
damage is deep and wide states
localities municipalities their budgets
are blown apart we're gonna lose a thank
goodness
Hillsdale is in great shape but there
are a lot of small liberal arts colleges
that are in trouble right now serious
trouble there are hospitals that are in
trouble
that the damage goes way deeper than
then people understand and and and I
think the pressure on governor's to open
up is going to grow by the day partly
because the federal government doesn't
have enough money to bail them out
completely and then I know we'll get
into this in a minute but one of the
things that worries me the most is that
we have now set a new precedent that
anytime we start to have a flu uh virus
spread that we're going to shut down the
economy again and if we do that then the
behavior of every citizen in America the
behavior of every company will change
we're gonna see people hold a lot more
cash be a lot more wary of life and that
will slow growth down for the long term
and it's going to take a while for us to
get back to normal especially if people
think the government's going to react
like this at any day well the tools are
in place now the as you said from 2008
and then this this incredible prestige
that scientists have right I know a
story Winston Churchill was at his worst
political setback in the First World War
and where it started was the generals
had enormous prestige and the British
Constitution doesn't set up a commander
in chief it's better now because he
performs some things and so no
politician could stand up to them and
they sacrificed nine hundred thousand
British lives fighting back and forth
across two miles of ground which they
never got beyond that until the war
ended the German the German army family
broke but that's you know an incredible
cost and Churchill developed a whole
account of all this and and his point
was really simple
experts by definition can only know one
thing really well but decisions are made
by many things and so like what kind of
person would you know you're you're an
expert on a par with the greatest
epidemiologist but your expertise
teaches you some humility about what you
know there doesn't seem to ya and that's
that's the thing I mean I what I have
done from the very beginning I'm an
economist that's my job but I was also
I'm a mathematician and statistician I'm
not an epidemiologist I'm not an expert
in pandemics I never have claimed I was
but I know how models work and I have
dug into these models I have looked at
data and and the data said over and over
and over again whether we look at other
countries around the world whether we
look back in history whether we look at
the data that we have today that that we
were overstating the death rate
overstating a lot of things now people
are dying and and one of the problems
this is why they call you a coronavirus
tire denier is is that you don't care
that people are dying that's absolutely
not true it breaks my art my mother and
father are 86 and 85 they live in a
retirement community I worry about them
every day they don't have good news is
they're in great health I don't really
want to talk about them a lot but but I
worry about them every day they're in an
environment that's that's that's
dangerous but for most people this isn't
as dangerous there there are studies out
already one in Chelsea Massachusetts one
in Santa Clara California and one in LA
that show the death rate is
significantly lower than was initially
estimated that's why these models have
gone from 2.2 million to 240 thousand to
a hundred thousand to sixty thousand
because they they always overestimate
and it's because we it's the fog of war
we don't have enough data and yet
they're using models and and assuming
that they have
data that they don't really have and and
then what this does is it causes fear
and and then what what's fascinating to
me is I mean clearly there's a political
dimension to this and the the latest
thing everyone is grabbed on to is
testing we we have to be able to test
more well at the same time I keep
hearing over and over again on TV
reading it in print that hey if you've
had kovat 19 you could get it again
that's what a lot of press are reporting
they're interviewing people and doctors
that say that and so then the question I
have is well then what good is testing
because if you test negative well that
means you could get it tomorrow and if
you test as if you have that you have
antibodies well then they're saying you
could get it again so so really what
they're saying is you could never do
enough testing ever if people can
actually get it again and by the way if
you could get it again then there's no
vaccine that could fix it because
antibodies don't work and that's the way
that vaccines work and so what they've
done is they've set up an argument that
no one can defeat and that really scares
me it's almost like climate change and
the the one thing that I find
fascinating is they said the world was
going to end in 12 years with climate
change and that wasn't enough to scare
people into letting the government take
over their lives but but now they say
you could dive tomorrow from cove at 19
and now people many people have been
willing to let the government take over
their lives the good news is we're
seeing people across the country say no
more we're not putting up with this and
and i think as this spreads if let's say
i have a manufacturing plant in one
state in indiana and indiana opens up
and i start producing and and you're a
manufacturer in michigan and I'm
competing for the same customers well
guess what you're gonna be pushing your
governor to open up too because now
you're going to be losing business and
so as different places start to
open up I think it will spread and the
the opening up will spread and that that
will get the economy back but but if
this is a new paradigm if this is the
new way that we deal with every virus
it's worrisome for the future because at
that point investing is a lot riskier
than it's ever been before and it's not
just because of competition or regular
old business cycles you know recessions
in the economy it's because at any
moment the government may decide we're
gonna shut down and I think it's just
it's based on models that are flawed and
and and they won't admit that they're
flawed it's it's scary really when you
think about it there has to be some
systemic reason why these models are
continuously wrong what do you think
that is yeah as I look at them I mean I
don't want to act like I'm an
epidemiologist here but as I look at
them there's there's two things that
they are based on and that is one how
quickly it spreads and then how deadly
it is and and so so if you put in
slightly different numbers for those two
things you can come up with numbers like
2.2 million people dying but here's the
problem we can't measure everyone so for
example let me let me run through some
data and I hope I do this well enough so
that people can follow the numbers
there's quite a few numbers here but
right now the CDC Center for Disease
Control says that in the US for this flu
season 2019 to 2020
somewhere between 39 million and 56
million people have had the flu okay now
that is an estimate it's a complete
estimate all right now I get it we have
a lot of history with the flu they're
using it's probably pretty close okay
however here's the problem we've only
tested 1.3 million people in the United
States we did
test 39 million we didn't test 56
million we only tested 1.3 million and
of those 1.3 million 224 two hundred two
hundred and forty seven thousand tested
positive for the flu now let's go to
look at deaths here's what the CDC says
about deaths they say between 24 and
fifty six thousand people a year die
from or this year have died from the flu
so if we use the lowest number 24,000
divided by the number of positive tests
which is two hundred and forty seven
thousand it gives you a death rate of
about ten percent and and when we're
dealing with kovat 19 we have not done
broad studies to be able to estimate the
full number of people that have it all
we know is the number of people that
have tested positive and so when we
compare the people who tested positive
to the to the people who have died we
end up with a much bigger death rate
than then is true because it this this
Cova 19 has spread much further and much
wider than we're able to know today
because we now we've done a few antibody
studies and they show that that's true
but but nobody wants to believe them yet
because we have it done perfectly
fda-approved random samples and and this
is this is one of the by the way the
same thing happens with with a vaccine
you know everybody keeps saying 18
months well you know it doesn't take 18
months to make a vaccine it take eight
it takes 18 months for the FDA to
approve it and and and so so what's
what's fascinating about this is that
they're they're the bureaucracies get in
the way they're working with data that
is not complete and they're using
numbers that are way too big and so I I
think that's one of the reasons why
these models consistently overestimate
is that we're always coming in with data
that that's lacking I would never make a
forecast of the economy with the data
that they are using
ever alright and and yet they're able to
to shut down the economy with that data
and I think that's a huge mistake
do you think there's any relevance to
the fact that these big bureaucracies
also provide a lot of funding to
scientists oh absolutely
I mean we see it with climate change
there is so much money thrown around to
study climate change and now with
pandemics plus you know if you look at
university health department's many of
them get grants from the NIH when they
I'm not sure whether the FDA and CDC
provide grants but but I'm sure they're
involved in the process and so the
bureaucracies end up where they mean
this this whole world of researchers in
this area is pretty small all right and
I mean they know each other and and here
that's one of the things that was
frustrating to me at the very beginning
of this is that we we know the CDC and
the FDA messed up that first test and
yet there's there's 600 people out there
800 that maybe it's 1,600 I'm not even
sure who work in private companies who
work in university labs who are
brilliant who are just as brilliant as
anybody at the CDC or the FDA but the
bureaucracies wouldn't let go and then
finally they let go you know one of the
fascinating things that I found out
about South Korea is that 90% of the
testing that was done in South Korea was
done by private companies 90% and so no
wonder they were able to roll it out as
fast as they were and and we haven't
done that here in fact we're still using
government labs to run the test
well quest Diagnostics a private company
governors and and cities and states and
municipalities aren't using their
capacity to do tests and they should be
but what's fascinating is the
bureaucracies hold on to the power and
they hold on to the data too and as and
one and here's another issue I didn't
even think about it until right now and
that is that in the cares act in that
big two trillion dollar spending
there is a there's a section about
Medicare reimbursements for Co vyd 19
deaths and if you have a kovat patient
that dies in your hospital they you get
a 15% boost to the payment for that
category of death now I sort of get it
it's it's combat pay all right
however what that does is it creates an
incentive you know there might be
somebody that that was only gonna live
another two weeks because they had a
congenital heart disease and and and and
that was it but if they have kovat 19
they get categorized as dying by kovat
19 even though we only saved about two
weeks of their life or we only lost
excuse me about two weeks of their life
and and this is a whole nother issue
with economics and i this is in a way
morbid and I almost don't like talking
about what I'm about to say but if we
kind of look at the number of years of
life lost because of kovat 19 it's not
like the Spanish flu which was killing
young young children teenagers people in
their 20s 30s 40s it was indiscriminate
as to as depending on age we know the
people that are dying from kovin 19 and
and so if we compare it to other
pandemics other deadly viruses in the
economy just happens to be that this one
is is 97 percent of all the people who
have died in New York City had had
underlying conditions most of them
multiple underlying conditions and so so
their life was already in a sense on the
edge and then the virus pushed them over
now I I don't I mean I want to cry it's
not a great way to go and and so you
know one of the things I want everybody
to know is is that is that look I every
life is precious and if somebody can be
with a family for another two or three
weeks that's two or three weeks that's
on ful II get that but to shut down the
entire economy and I believe to create
much greater long term health care
problems
we're not balancing that out and that's
what the the pandemic experts don't
include in their models is the damage
that comes from from long term slower
growth from from bigger government and
and less freedom and more unemployment
it we know that leads to more death more
disease and and and and and shorter
lifespans all we have to do is look
anywhere around the world and we can see
that and so we need to balance those two
things out and that's what I'm
suggesting is that the the the data on
the virus isn't great enough to have
done the damage that we have done to the
economy unanswered question about
employment and unemployment looks to me
like one of the glories of the American
economy in the last four years is the
very low rates of unemployment and how
employment is reaching into places with
low income people and long term
unemployed where it hasn't been for
decades why do you think that happened
and how do we get that back yeah I think
I think it happened for a couple of
reasons number one it was an 11 year
long economic recovery and I get it it
was it was slow alright but but when
President Trump came in we were in the
fours in an unemployment and then he was
able to push it down to three and a half
percent which is the lowest we've seen
in 50 years and I think there's there's
two key reasons for that number one we
cut corporate tax rates it was the
United States had one of the highest
well in fact there's a couple of really
teeny countries so if all we do is look
at developed countries around the world
we have the highest corporate tax rate
in the world and and so what we were
doing is we were pushing business to
Canada to to Mexico to China to France
to Italy to Spain I mean in all these
countries had lower tax rates then than
we do
and now what we have done is we have
come become competitive at 27% with and
that's including state and federal and
state taxes we've become competitive
with all these countries and we're
starting to bring business back to the
u.s. number two
we deregulated in fact President Trump
deregulated more in my opinion than even
Ronald Reagan who up until now was the
record holder but but president Trump
has done a massive deregulatory effort
which has freed up onshore every time
you get rid of a regulation you free up
an entrepreneur to do something else and
so what happened is we were already at
low levels of unemployment we now have
to reach into areas where people were
reluctant to work because they were
getting unemployment benefits and
welfare almost on a permanent basis but
now it was more beneficial to get a job
and so we started pulling people out of
these areas where we're up until then
they had refused to work and so so the
economy picked up a little bit we had
lower tax rates less regulation and
that's why we were getting to that point
and and what's fascinating about this is
that that would have led to a healthier
economy it would have led to less and
more and fewer problems with health with
with with just about anything that's the
and this is the frustrating part to me
Larry I know I'm kind of bouncing off
onto an angle here but but every dollar
that government spends every dollar that
supports a liberal arts college in the
middle of Vermont which is now going
bankrupt comes from the private sector
our every dollar it doesn't government
does not create wealth and so what we
have done today is literally shut down
the wealth creating mechanism in the
economy and then what happens is the the
this is I believe people way under my
estimated the economic damage that would
ripple through the economy
I mean for example the you know in in in
just in up out all food categories even
in toilet paper there's two different
supply chains one goes to the individual
through the grocery store let's say and
the other goes it goes to the individual
eventually but it goes through business
restaurants hotels office buildings and
and so what's happened is is that no
wonder we had a shortage of toilet paper
and some food items because because we
weren't ready for everybody to stay at
home we're expecting people to use
bathrooms in both places
we're expecting people to eat tomatoes
in both places eat eggs in both places
and so what's happening now is that
every day we stay closed that supply
chain is destroyed
and and and and and and so it takes time
for that to come back now I believe it
will come back but it takes time and
that's why I'm looking for a you like I
know it's not the perfect letter but
we're not going to be back to normal for
quite some time at least a couple of
years people think you can turn off an
economy and then just turn it right back
on you can't it doesn't work that way
and so my view is that the damage from
this is going to end up being a lot more
than people think hope this doesn't
become a way of life yeah well I I think
that's the biggest problem well just
imagine you know running a business
thinking that any day now any day now
well you know we could be shut down
there's a virus in in China and that's
it we're not going to take any risk
we're gonna shut everything down again
and so how do you run a business or plan
for the future if that's if that's
likely to be true you know and I I go
back and look at how we behaved and
other crises SARS and MERS and the swine
flu and hiv/aids we never shut the
economy down and and I I mean I know I
make these arguments and then I get
called a denier and nobody wants to
listen
but but but the CDC publishes death
figures every week and and and 50 over
50,000 people a week it's 52 53 54
thousand but over 50,000 of people every
week in the u.s. die now they died of
tuberculosis heart disease cancer auto
accidents gunshots like there's there's
a lot of different ways people die but
it's 50,000 people a week which means
250 200 sees me 2.5 2.6 million people
every year and yet we don't count these
things up in the corner of a cable news
show we don't count the flu deaths up in
the corner of enabled Nate of a cable
news show even though we know somewhere
between 25 and 60 million people die
from the flu every year or at least
that's what we think we know and and so
if we have now started down this road
where we're not willing to take any risk
at all that's a dangerous thing you know
I kind of my analogy is hey if you're if
you play the game of football and you're
a running back and the quarterback hands
you the ball and and and and all of a
sudden you start thinking well I could
break my leg on this play and then what
you do is you fall down in the backfield
well well guess what there's no game of
football if everybody worries about
getting injured on every single play
everybody stops playing and so and
that's the same thing with with the
economy if we worry that any day it's
going to come to an end we're gonna see
a lot less risk taking because we've
just increased the risk of operating a
business in this economy so
scientifically driven industries
healthcare Public Health especially it
and they have models that have been
consistently wrong for a long time right
that you know and there's no method of
discipline I mean if you work and if you
were wrong all the time
you know I like you great but you're on
this show because you're very serious
guy and you and you get things right so
in that odd it's government it's what it
is
yep friend of mine actually friend of
mine wrote complaining that Russ vote
whom I happen to know was in the Office
of Management budget was talking about
cuts to the budget of the Centers for
Disease Control and my friend wrote and
said well that's a crazy thing to do
right now and I said well there are two
ways to look at that one is look up what
they're doing that doesn't have anything
to do with communicable diseases which
is their original charter actually they
were founded to study communicable
diseases for national defense purposes
and they spend a lot of money now on
lifestyle health issues in other words
that that permits them to work very
broadly go all over the place right but
the second thing is if their job is to
control of the disease how are they
doing if they want to raise I mean
that's not you know right if things rain
like that around here in Hillsdale
College I'd be looking for a job right
and that's why it's so I mean that's why
the the ability of these pandemic
experts to use models that overestimate
it means that both politicians and the
the the modelers the doctors can claim
victory at the end and I'm not saying
that they set it up exactly for that
reason I I'm not I mean I've been I've
found myself getting more cynical lately
but I'm not a I'm not a pure cynic yet
and I hope I never am but but the bottom
line I don't think they purposely make
the models high just so they can claim
victory but that's the end result and
that's a political process and that's
one of the problems with having
government do this and you know we hear
about it all the time you know you if
you're talking about climate change well
then then there's no way that Exxon
Mobil can ever
have you do a study because if you do
then it's tainted well the government it
as Milton Friedman said long ago where
are all these angels just because you're
in government doesn't mean you're an
angel and people people kind of
gravitate toward more power if you're a
business you want you want to have more
customers you want to have a bigger
company you want to make more profits
and if you're in government you want to
control more of activity you want to
have more power it's the same thing
there are no angels these are our people
and when they have this can kind of
control over life it's scary and and and
the good news is what I see is that
people in America many people in America
are fed up they're they're like ok we we
went along with you originally but now
we're we're looking at data you know and
and we're seeing the data and and one I
mean social media has a negative it
helps create panic but it also has a
positive and that that is it gives a
voice to people that have alternative
views and I I get it there's people that
attack you all the time they call you a
denier etc but at least those ideas can
get out there and inform the public
debate I kind of look back you know
March 18th
I did a Twitter storm about the damage
from the shutdown of the economy the
next day and I'm not saying that they
did this because of me but the next day
the Wall Street Journal editorial page
wrote a an editorial about the damage
done from shutting down the economy then
a few days later Dana Perino who was the
one of the spokespeople in the Bush
White House said they ought to come up
with an economic corona virus virus task
force because we know the damage from
the economy is is something that we're
not accounting for and and then it's
it's sort of spread from there and I'm
not like that whole story was not to say
that I started it or anything there's
they believe there's people that come up
with the same ideas hundreds thousands
of miles
part at the same moment it's just
because we're all looking at similar
things and so that was awesome but with
just in a few days and then boom the
next thing you know we're talking about
hey when can we open up the economy and
so so what's what's good about that is
that we are starting to see the other
side of this and and and the sooner the
sooner we open up the less and long the
damage will be both short term and long
term the problem is we've done we've
done damage right now that's going to
last at least a couple of years and
maybe longer
and and I and I've said this a couple of
times today there's two there's two big
fears that I have one is that we've made
this a kind of a standard way standard
operating procedure procedure for the
future all right and the other problem
is that government has just permanently
grown everybody got a bigger budget out
of that two trillion dollar deal a lot
of it went to businesses and to
individuals but but just about every
agency in the government got more money
and and so so we have just permanently
grown the size of the government and so
those two things worry me about the
future bigger government means a smaller
private sector and and then this
standard operating procedure potential
of shutting down the economy anytime we
want that's also going to meet the
private sector behaves in a much less
they're gonna have much more risk
aversion than they would have otherwise
because now you've just added a whole
new risk to their life I think the
economy makes about two trillion a month
is that right the whole economy so
roughly
yeah and we're about we're 20 to 23
trillion a year so if you take a month
off and nobody produces anything that's
what you lose and and that looks like
then we've transferred money from the
public sector to the private sector
paying all this money out but the truth
is the public sectors borrowed the money
and the private sector is gonna have to
pay it back and was the source of the
money to begin with
that's exactly right so you could in a
way almost think of it as a four
trillion dollar problem because because
we lost two trillion in production we
added two trillion and in future debt
actually more because the federal tax
receipts are gonna fall by by probably
probably twelve to fifteen percent this
year going right I think we're gonna
lose five hundred billion dollars just
in individual taxes because because
people aren't working States and and
municipalities are losing sales taxes on
top of that and so what we have done is
we've exploded that the budget deficit
was already scheduled to be about a
trillion dollars we added 2.2 trillion
of new spending looks like this new bill
is gonna be 500 so that add that up it's
three point seven trillion then you take
500 million in revenue and now you're a
four point two trillion so so not only
did we lose two trillion in production
but we have four point two trillion or
more of debt that our children and
grandchildren and great-grandchildren
are gonna have to repay and and in
economic terms there there's a theory
out there called modern modern monetary
theory most people have it's it's been
out there MMT aoc believes in this and
others but that you can just print money
and borrow money at will the problem
with that is that the only way you can
ever make that money worth anything or
pay back the debt is to produce and and
if you and if you only have a government
you're not producing government doesn't
produce new things I'm not saying that
they don't fund research and and we
invent things because we went to the
moon and into space and it said that
that have changed that you know helped
change the world I'm not saying that
they but but they aren't the
entrepreneurs they they don't create the
wealth over time it's it's the
entrepreneurs that do it's the small mid
large businesses
it's the individual proprietors those
are the people that create wealth and
without them without producing we can't
pay back that debt and so so if today
what we're doing is we're telling you
okay you start a business but if you
don't have three months of cash on hand
at all times
you know and we shut down because of the
next virus
too bad you're going out of business or
we're gonna have to spend even more of
your children's money to save you you're
not you're much less likely to take risk
you're much less likely to be an
entrepreneur and and and then and that's
one of the reasons why I go look I you
know I added up Spain and Italy and
France and Germany for the biggest
countries in Europe but then I added
Belgium Netherlands and Switzerland
now I didn't I picked them kind of at
random so I'd get reasonably close to
the US as population so those seven
countries have 292 million people we
have 330 million people well guess what
in those countries the total deaths from
kovat are twice as high as ours they're
over eighty thousand versus forty
thousand and I believe one of the key
reasons is that for decades they've
grown slowly because they have big
government they have socialized medicine
and they've under invested in their
health care system and so so that's our
future we're gonna end up having more
people die because of slower growth then
then then if we hadn't shut the economy
down I and I fully get it that if you're
not out in public you're not gonna give
it to anybody else I totally understand
that but we but we've estimated the
death rate is way higher than it really
is we're looking at Sweden and they're
not run away and they don't they haven't
closed their economy down and so there's
a lot of evidence that what we're doing
is creating damage which in the long run
maybe not next month or next year but in
the long run could create way more death
than this
today and and I don't know why our risk
profile has changed so much it's it's
really amazing is it social media is it
is it just the extent of news and how
it's purported is it all politics I'm
not sure but we have we've gone into a
risk aversion a cowering or that running
back in the back field who will not take
the ball from the quarterback because he
might break his leg and and so it's
that's that's what I see today happening
in the economy and it's one of the
reasons why I do worry about the future
let's talk a little bit about what
should be done now what what what can
the Congress and the president do to
help get us out of this as fast as
possible yeah you know so all right if
here's I mean I'd love to hear your
comment on this Larry because you're a
constitutional scholar and and and and
sort of the way if you're gonna force
businesses to shut down isn't that
really a taking right it's a we could
call it the equivalent of a taking and
then in a taking there's supposed to be
just compensation so so I'm just gonna
take this head-on for a second and say
if the government forces you to shut
down then in a way it has to give you
just compensation so so these these
loans to small businesses the direct
payment to people that are out of work
the the use of federal reserve funds to
kind of keep the the markets calm and
and to provide liquidity to the markets
in a way that's a just compensation for
the taking now we just talked about what
that means for the future and having to
pay back that debt but in a way that
we're we're compensating people for the
taking it is that a in your opinion is
that a good way to look at it
constitutionally
even though we know it might cause
damage I think I think that's the way
President Trump looks at it by the way
he said things like that yeah all right
and so so then but but but here's what
happens
that is that we know that this is
unsustainable because the because the
the damage keeps spreading and every day
it spreads further that revenues to
states and municipalities are falling
it's businesses are going out that will
never come back and it's and a lot of it
has nothing to do with the money that
the federal government is throwing at it
it's just because the rest of lot of
small businesses just operate on really
thin margins and and can't last even
just to even a few weeks and so so we
have to get this thing open and here's
kind of the way I see this happening and
we're already seeing a couple of dozen
states it looks like to me I won't try
to list them all I probably miss 10 or
add to that shouldn't be there but but
some are beginning to open and they're
opening in phases they or they're
opening even wider than the president's
guidelines and they're doing it more
quickly and I think that that starts to
spread so if Ohio opens then Michigan
and Indiana have more pressure to open
because now the companies in Ohio have
an advantage over the companies in
Michigan and then the pressure on the
governor or on the assembly grows to get
things open and then once once if Ohio
opens and Pennsylvania opens then that
puts pressure on New York City in fact
New York City is now opening hospitals
to do elective and and needed surgeries
finally and so even Governor Cuomo who
promised to stay shut down until mid-may
is beginning to open things up and so I
think the pressure is going to build
plus we have people and companies who
are just gonna open they're just going
to go back to work they're gonna be out
there it's all it's almost in a way
civil disobedience and and and what I
think that's just going to put I think
we're on on the way it is not going to
take till the end of May
now if we have some major spike in
new cases or you know something like
that which this is why I'm not an
epidemiologist I don't know whether
that's going to happen or not what I
will say is that the data suggests to me
that 30% of Americans have already had
this and so we are developing a herd
immunity just like we do to the flu do
with the flu and and the bottom line is
as I don't think we're gonna see a new
spike but but then again you know please
don't you know come after me you know
for being wrong but I don't think we
will but this pressure is going to
spread now
that you know so that would mean from
the middle of March kind of until the
early part of May let's call it mid May
for two months we've been shut down
that's a lot of damage to the economy
and it's going to take time to heal and
and I'm not being pessimistic about this
I'm just saying it is and and it it bums
me out we were at record high stock
market highs record low unemployment and
it's going to take us a couple of years
to get back to where we were as long as
we don't shut it down again and that's
my biggest fear is that it's not that we
can't open and recover yeah you know a
lot of hedge funds out there now I lost
count of the billions of dollars but
it's probably over a hundred billion
dollars have started gathering funds to
buy distressed debt because there are
going to be a lot of of deals pennies on
the dollar kind of deals to be able to
buy firms that got into financial
trouble because they had too much debt
going into this and then didn't survive
Neiman Marcus just closed or went into
bankruptcy the other day and so there
there are people out there that see
advantages that they can take and
investments that they can make and
that's going to help get the economy
open that's the magic above creative
destruction of capitalism and bankruptcy
I mean it's it's because it it allows
money to be shifted into resources one
of the things that's going to happen in
my opinion is is that oil leases and the
the
price of drilling rigs and equipment is
going to fall because there are some oil
companies that had too much debt and
can't survive and so then those that had
a lot of cash and a deep and and
well-structured balance sheet are gonna
be able to pick up leases and equipment
cheaper we saw this back in 2014 and 15
when oil prices fell and but what
that'll do is it actually ratchets down
the production costs in the Permian
Basin in the Bakken in our in our shale
fields and so we'll be able to have a
lower breakeven point and so
bankruptcies yeah they're terrible for
those who have to go through them but
for the economy as a whole it allows us
to restructure things and sometimes we
come out in a more efficient way but it
takes time and that's why I'm saying
it's going to be two years before we
fully recover in the economy probably a
little bit less in the stock market
because it will see the full recovery
coming but I always put the caveat on
there and that is that's if the
government doesn't shut us down again
because they have done tremendous damage
and if they do it again it will just
make it mean that it's going to take a
lot longer to get back to where we were
so this is a sort of extreme form of the
heavy regulatory taxing state right and
to the extent we go back to that to the
extent that this is a trigger for going
back to that then it could take a really
long time to get back yeah exactly
yeah I mean that the more regulation we
have I mean we saw it during President
Obama Obama's tenure that the higher the
tax rates the more regulation the more
government control the slower we grow
and you know we have I think back about
this last 10 11 12 years as has been
miraculous actually if you look back at
the last 30 years it's been miraculous
well you know even before that Gordon
Moore at Intel events the computer chip
etc but but the
iPhone 11 that meat stands for 11 years
it's only been around for 11 1/2 12
years that's it the cloud has been
around less apps have been around less
and I think about what we are able to do
even I mean the good news is business
even though it was all stay-at-home a
lot of business still was getting done
because of the technologies that we've
invented and and and that's the only way
we were able to grow
I believe in President Obama's tenure is
because government got bigger and a lot
of libertarians and a lot of us
Austrians said oh no we're gonna be in
depression any day and my argument
always was look I don't like higher
taxes I don't like more regulation but
technology is so powerful today you know
the cloud apps the the the the the
smartphone this the the iPad all all the
3d printing we cracked the genome and
and by the way one of the reasons why I
expect a vaccine to come more quickly is
because we cracked the genome we can now
model these things on computers and be
pretty certain that we've got the right
thing it's it's like building an
airplane you can model it on a computer
without a part and know that it will fly
alright and and so tracking the genome
that is is I mean I think we're gonna
have healthcare companies and biotech
companies come out of this as heroes and
so so let me let me tell you the
opposite way that this could go and that
is that we're gonna find out that the CD
CDC and the FDA did not save our lives
that this was a virus was way more
prevalent than we thought that the death
rate is much closer to the flu and that
we panicked for no reason and we're
never gonna let that go it happen again
and not only that but it was the private
companies wrote the Roush's the abbot's
the 3d printers who are now doing nasal
swabs and they you know that that and
they're printing millions and millions
and millions and millions of them that
they're literally saved the day
and and if that story can be put out
there along with the fact that socialism
and socialist social welfare states and
Italy Spain and France failed relative
to us they closed down their economies
too but they have a lot more deaths and
it's because their healthcare system
didn't have enough investment in it and
so so I kind of can see this go one of
two ways that that we that we embrace
the private sector for for its victories
and and and we and we point the finger
at the government for its failures and
and that's going to be the battle for
the narrative as we come out of this but
it's it is going to be the the drug
companies and the biotech firms that are
the ones that develop the vaccines the
antibody tests that and and and testing
in general that roll things out that are
able that are going to be able to make
people more comfortable we're also going
to see that they can move faster than
ever before and this is one of the
things the president has done is he's
kind of forced the FDA to kind of calm
down to to stop you know stop slowing
people down in their research and and I
think you know the more the FDA looks at
this the more they're gonna realize that
cracking the genome especially when it
comes to a virus was one of the most
important developments of our lifetimes
and in health care that is and it's
going to let us move faster on vaccines
than we ever have before so that could
be a real positive that comes out of
this as well so Brian that's our time
and I want to say two things
Lincoln said if we could know where we
are and whether we are tending we could
better know what to do and how to do it
you've helped us that a mountain and I
am grateful to you for teaching the
economics every Monday morning I invite
the rest of you to go learn from him and
Brian thank you very much Larry thank
you so so great to have been with you